in our ion birth series we're looking
ahead to a landmark United Nations
climate action summit next week CBS this
morning is showcasing original reporting
we like that focusing on the health of
our planet like that do scientists say
that climate change is increasing the
intensity and frequency of heavy
rainstorms coastal cities are doing
their best to prepare for the threat of
severe flooding from storms and
potentially large rises in sea level
Nicky batiste toured to communities
turning to nature for help she's in Long
Island City New York with more on the
story Nicky good to see you good morning
hi hi Gail good morning flooding from
storm surges and heavy rainfall can be
one of the most devastating effects of a
storm to protect cities from flooding
Engineers often build sea walls and
levees but now there's a new and much
prettier approach public parks like this
one that are also storm resistant on the
edge of New York's East River is an
urban oasis Hunter's Point South Park
there are rows of seasonal plants waves
lapping at the shore winding paths and
breathtaking views but look closer we
use materials that are rugged and plant
material it is salt tolerant Tom balsley
designed this park he says the landscape
while beautiful also shields the
community from super storms if the water
rises and comes in here this synthetic
turf actually soaks it up yes it's it's
absorbent in a big heavy storm we almost
have a half a million gallons of water
being held here detained until the tide
or the storm leaves and then it goes
right back to the river
flowerbeds disguise a ditch and
filtration system that capture and
slowly release water back into the river
an outer wall protects marshes that fill
an empty with the tide but can be fully
submerged in a storm you said that you
designed these projects to bend so they
don't break
what's that philosophy well that's in a
way that's what resilience is isn't it
it can take those storms it can take the
hit but you know it's going to bounce
back just over 100 miles south the
community of South Bridge in Wilmington
Delaware is and only battling super
storms down here this was told the
underwater they're battling every storm
when it rains and the Christiana River
water rises above the floodgate
floodgate cannot open so the water just
backs up into the neighborhood activists
Marvin Thomas Emery Reed have lived in
this waterlogged community most of their
lives what do you remember from your
childhood not sleeping the night it
rained my father would say all hands on
deck because that means everybody's
going to the basement ready to take
buckets and what to get the flooding
after decades of pushing for change they
may finally see some relief this summer
the city broke ground on the South
wilmington wetlands park a project
designed to stop the flooding in much of
the community and will accomplish that
by putting a series of new stormwater
pipes in the roads throughout the
Southbridge community those pipes will
divert water into this wetland park and
eventually to the channels where it will
circulate and then move into the
Christina River but this hard-fought
victory only solves flooding for roughly
two-thirds of the neighborhood do you
think if this were a wealthy white
community that you would have had change
decades ago yes it seemed orbital smile
at you Maria's going to tell you yes I
do it was been rectified a long time ago
when did you start thinking about this
back in the seventies when superstorm
wasn't really on our minds or something
we were conscious of how did you have
that foresight I lived here wilmington
city planners say they hope to fix the
remaining flooding in south bridge with
a future wetlands project they're also
joining cities across the country by
looking at ways to protect their
communities from longer-term concerns
like sea-level rise boston wants to
build a more resilient coastline and
anthony houston is already transforming
its bayou system into parks that manage
flooding like this one
nikki thank you it's a battle where
we've just begun to fight the effects
are not equally felt no and I like that
they're spreading the word I like when
she said he's going to smile at you i'ma
tell you the truth yes